I haven't seen in a while and I didn't
know that you had dropped in anyway so I
see now uh yeah ii doing alright what
make you what made you start down that
road did you I want to or do you not
wanting to die is a motivator hahaha
that's right with ya do you notice that
this what I noticed too it happened with
guy that I know is he did older and when
people you know start dying of natural
causes we all know people kill
themselves oh it's all the guard it's so
weird
hey I was friends of Patton Oswald's
wife oh yeah I didn't know her I know
Patton lobbies was a great woman he was
just so lucky she was just a rocker as a
matter of fact the thing I'm coming to
promote my next mystery movie I would
call her to ask her things were real
would somebody do this because she knew
everything about police procedure she
knew everything about murder and her
website still up by the way she's a
great writer what is she doing she was a
writer of a crime or not to come i'll
true crime crime yeah
and so she'd you spend all the time
research yeah it's called true crime
diary patents left it up the writing
there is impeccable i really look
forward to her book she has a book
coming out so she would write about
famous cases or king all he didn't know
about figure them out oh and we take a
lot because of her she wasn't she was
born to have a TV series based on her
what if she died did you see the nice
natural cause think the natural cause
things um Wow okay yeah and yes it was
just a freak accident right but it sucks
like and Jeannie Gaffigan Jim gravity's
wife had an emergency brain surgery like
once you start knowing people that have
[ __ ] go wrong yep you're like [ __ ] me
I'm getting older because a people are
dying or having medical stuff like yeah
I got taken out myself
you're a vulnerable thing when you're
you and Ben are you single
no I'm married oh yeah I didn't even
okay yeah I don't believe in marriage
but I'm married well how long 20 would
be 24 years this summer so before all
the same happened yes because also you
know that by the way I actually have no
interest in that you know in terms of
like being with anyone who's like you
know and by the way most people would be
with me would be because of the fame but
all
interested in people who want to [ __ ] me
because you might why are you not
interested in groupies but it's it's
meaningless to me right it is I'd rather
have a nice nap at this point in your
life here while you're successful oh
because you're not concentrating on
[ __ ] like Bill Gates all those guys
don't concentrate on [ __ ] they
concentrate on their work in their
career and I'm building up my own
Microsoft and that's what I'm doing
no marriage is antiquated yeah alchemy
is antiquated
monogamy is great if you want to be
monogamous it's fantastic good for you
and it does take a lot off your plate it
doesn't I mean like there's nothing to
worry about nothing to worry about let's
do other so it's great if you want to
but it's all stuff we marriage was
invented for what people who lived 230
that's a good point and I also think
like the whole monogamy thing my theory
on that is way back in biblical times
there was no cure for VD so you wanted a
virgin and because if a girl had
something with her um you know she was a
virgin you didn't have anything and that
would kill you suddenly is where a lot
of that probably came from if you had
one that was clean you [ __ ] kept this
yeah yeah have you ever wanted to not be
monogamous I mean I mean I always want
to not be the moment is it hard no it's
hard it's hard to be faithful no for me
it always was no no I mean it is but no
it's not the women that I want to be
with are my friends and they're not the
kind of women that [ __ ] a married man I
said I never feel like I can't [ __ ] my
friends I have lots of friends I want to
have sex yeah but that's not who they
are right and I get why the hell do I be
with a groupie I don't I mean I don't
know these people because for me as I
get older it's more of an emotional
thing than a physical thing you know
when you're in your 20s I this is me I
would have sex with a girl I hated if I
thought she was hot
sure that's virtually impossible right
now if I didn't dig and respect somebody
and didn't have a personal connection I
don't even know if I could get a boner
but there's a personality type to that
when you get mecca's I do the same thing
like you're going to stay monogamous
because it's just your personality but
you end up making friends with all the
women that you would have wanted to have
sex with and also because it they will
be friends with you but even if you were
single they probably I know in my case
wouldn't
yes she wrote a joke years ago I said
that I be I be on Melrose Avenue and I'd
see a pretty girl across the street and
I point at her and go man if I was
married I had still be standing here you
know you can kinda is it like a marriage
confidence where you can kid yourself
that yeah I could I could but no but the
reality is okay I'm not going to speak
for you but I'm guessing by the way you
talk there's a certain quality that you
have that is your your cynical warm real
person yeah but one other thing a woman
is going to eventually dig you you just
have to put in the work exactly okay not
like you walk up with a sister and boom
she's in its the putting in the work
exactly sister the reality is you could
pretty much get anyone you want if you
put in the work right you can and
they're really hitting yourself and I'm
talking about ridiculously beautiful
women all different types of women if
you have something in your soul you'll
eventually win but I'm married I have a
kid UTG so he does it he does cheat on
his wife but he's open about that oh
good I know I can tell by your eyes I do
not a lot of times I think what you're
saying is and I don't disagree like I
grow on people you grow on people like
none of us was bi except for Troy was
really handsome like any woman that ever
[ __ ] me it's never been like wow I got
it [ __ ] back it's like there's a
personality thing which makes them one
of you wrong women you told a woman that
you like to have things shoved in your
ass on a first date am i saying it's
I've never made missteps that's a first
date not third first she asked yeah yeah
she asked but then she had a bag full
tool so you but you you I you do change
what turns you on after a while like as
you get older I hate to say it but yeah
it is more mental I don't just like I
don't [ __ ] people the first time I hang
out with the minutes leaving I just
don't want to at this point look big
because it's there's nothing when you've
got that thing going when you're young
when I say young I'm about twenties
teens you know yeah you want to [ __ ] a a
hand puppet of a woman
and I mean you just wanna it's just like
let's go yeah I don't care and then it
becomes because by the way in Holly was
masters around a sock on but I'm a
shadow puppet by the way it didn't work
the way I wanted I am puppets fine but
they had a half of us fine - no but I'm
surrounded in LA by a beautiful woman I
see them every day I mean when you think
of who moves to Los Angeles it's the hot
girl from the school you know the right
not of bunnies kid from school hottest
girl from school all that stuff and so
unless there's a person there it's so
not interesting right oh yeah because
they're all over the place yeah there is
common as a Mexican or or a sushi
restaurant mixing like in LA you go into
any Mexican restaurant or any sushi
restaurant odds are it's great because
there anyway those are the only two kind
cuz they have to be to survive out there
because there's so many the competition
goes over the competition so you going
to one at worse it's going to be really
good goes how did you meet your wife was
she a performer or did you meet her
actually I met her she was my agent in
Chicago she likes to joke that she got
more than 10% okay so you met her and
you knew you loved her immediately or
don't go well no I knew I was charmed by
her I thought she was adorable but she
pursued me for almost a year
Wow yeah that's interesting so she just
liked what you did and I guess we got to
know each other and she's your agent or
no no and shouldn't even have them in
the opinions agent wise she brings about
everything not much that not about agent
one yeah and you're not even promoting
promote yet so it's called handsome my
net comes out in October I can tell you
that okay and that's like so I miss
Netflix mystery movies available
exclusively tomorrow on Netflix in this
Jeff Garlin a ga RLI an occasion on
Instagram or a Jeff Garlin official on
Facebook and I've heard it's really good
you play a kind of a detective Innis
yeah I play a homicide detective named
Jean Ansem and I'm really good at my job
is it all I'm not good at the other
stuff is it a hundred percent
scripted or is it a hundred dollars a
grift it is okay I should say a hundred
percent I encourage
actors that I direct and work with to
improvise if the moment takes us or I'll
say let's try this
but it's scripted yeah and you had and I
said I really just reminded me many
years ago you know Patrice was a very
loved guy on this show and and you you
had a nice moment with him mom I feel
like an unpleasant interaction at one
point we all are out it was unpleasant
but it wasn't that a very I'm not
mistaken I'm a I'm almost positive at
the moment it was on a show I've got he
you know my reputation is as an
improviser necessarily I don't have an
act I've never had nominations he never
was younger I did but since I've been
established I don't even act I literally
just go up and Patrice said to me as we
were sitting there on the air he goes is
that all the great Jeff Garlin has
that's it and I hadn't even started I
just said one thing and I go you are so
messing with the wrong guy and we were
ripping each other on the air all right
so I'm gonna say a lot of years but a
few years go by I'm standing on 57th
Street and and Broadway and Patrice
walks up to me and I go hey Patrice you
know and he goes hey man
I just want to apologize and I go you're
apologizing for the thing before I go
that's very nice of you
and it was so heartfelt and he was so
sincere about what he said to me that it
was coming from a place of insecurity
and all this stuff and I was so moved by
it we gave each other a big hug and Wow
yeah so yeah you know and I of course
was like everyone is I'm sure especially
you one of your best friends right just
devastated at losing him by the way I
always thought that's like was the
artist I always thought he was funny
always respected him so it did take me
to happen on the show like what well you
guys when you lean is doing on the show
I know because it's not here's the thing
I was more at that point of my life out
of control of my ego when I say out of
control rate I used to think I could
eliminate my ego that's ignorance but at
all times now hopefully I reckon
I go and I go no thank you don't need it
so but it was more of a defensive
response than an ego response because it
made me feel and look stupid like no I
can't do what I'm doing you know because
I said like two sentences hadn't even
got to it yet
okay what's not crazy to think Patrice
rubs someone the wrong way I know that
by my reputation but it's also becoming
a man
you realize certain things and obviously
it stayed with him yeah because he yam
up to me and that was really remarkable
well he felt bad about a lot I remember
you told me that all years ago and he
had started to regret a lot of things
and you were one of them and Lisa
Lampanelli was one of mistreated like it
was nice to see that if you know he was
we regretted a lot of the Dumber things
he did and we all have those dumb things
we do and unless you're a complete
jagoff if someone comes up in them see
that's the joke of it there's nothing
more confident than you can do then make
yourself vulnerable with another human
being and if the other human being
rejects you it's their problem it's
about them and it's really one of the
great moves of all time to be that way
and God bless him you know you know what
he did which shocked me it was it might
have been last time I know I'm the last
time I saw him but it was the summer
before he passed and we were at aunt's
house and he was barbecuing I remember
that and he had met Jess my wife years
before one of the traveling comedy tours
we were doing and it was when she was
still my girlfriend and he ignored her
as if she wasn't even in the room which
he did sometimes all of our fun yeah I
wondered who did that to my wife when
she was my girlfriend and he told me
ahead of time he goes you know I'm not
going to talk to her but really like
like she was offended by it as I can ask
for trees that's what he does I just
relax
and it kind of sat with her for years
and so I was like let's go say hi to
Patrice and she hadn't seen him so we
walked up to him and I wanted to kind of
give him the out and act like they'd
never met and I was like hey Patrice
this is my wife Jess I would walk and
instantly he goes oh no I remember when
we met before and I was an [ __ ] sorry
about that and like wow
their hand said hello is it like but by
the way when you do that too it frees
the wait yeah freeze because you don't
you wonder a long times like you meet
somebody and there's a lot of crap going
on with the way they're dealing with
your stuff and you wonder what are their
times alone like when they're laying in
bed and staring at the ceiling what are
they thinking of but also the opposite
of that is so many [ __ ] and truly
evil people think they're great people
yes and they never had that moment they
never at that moment they have no idea
that they're spectacular ly wrong yeah
yeah well when you're because you're
like a I feel like you'd do stuff a lot
you know I mean like you talk a lot like
are you are you an over-thinker or you
know no here's the thing man I am
completely gregarious and happy like I
am right now or I'm introverted I'm very
quiet and just stay to myself but those
are moments when I'm alone sometimes you
can't help it you're with other people
and you feel quiet but those are rare
for me when I'm around other people
I enjoy the exchange but when I do
Transcendental Meditation I want to ask
you about that key would you do it twice
a day what does it do for you and how
long do you do it okay it's 20 minutes a
day I mean 20 minutes per second per
session it's effortless and it there's
two things it helps you with that you
guys will be interested because there
are things it helps me sort of because
you go to you of your mantra but then
you float away and you think about
things that are going on you come up
with answers to your life and it goes
wait but you know what else you think of
funny stuff like it makes me so much
funnier to meditate and when he is oh
are you saying it's out there if you
want it because it makes it just both
things come to me and the weird thing is
you know like you'll be like aw remember
that later and you never remember that
later which is a classic thing at night
before I'll remember it in the morning
you never do you remember every funny
thing from meditation when you say like
you come up with ants like life answers
yeah are they good answers or is it like
shower thoughts where it's like you
think of something like yeah that's
perfect
and then by the time you drive
you realize it's no idea it's deeper
than that it is yeah and it's more like
what's going on but whenever you realize
that you've drifted away from your
mantra you come back to your mantra it's
like going back and forth but really
that's about the only effort it is when
do you do it first thing in the mean I
generally try to exercise do 20 minutes
on the air I wish win Aerodyne okay one
of the arms go back and forth here do 20
minutes of that and 20 minutes of
meditations and I have breakfast and
shower
okay so you start off with the meditate
and they said you do twice a day yeah
later
I try and do it like if I'm filming
sometimes I'll do it at lunch if I have
a vibe that I'm not them if we're not
set up yet I'll go off and say I'm doing
this for 20 minutes so and it was really
cool like if you're at a hotel or
someplace filming something he says
their quiet place I can go to they love
helping you and is it really uh like you
just sit there and you get into JH I'm
such a [ __ ] little disappoint but one
thing is that it you have to just give
yourself up to it but also go ahead and
scratch yourself okay go ahead and you
know move your head the the point thing
is it's not about tight rules yes keep
your eyes closed
yes try and repeat your mantra other
than that you're good and you know what
else I learned from my teacher and by
the way my teacher was this woman in her
90s she passed away a couple of years
ago her name was Nancy cooker era she
learned from the Maharishi and so I was
taught from one off from Amira she and
she was there with the Beatles and her
son was bungalow bill from the song
bungalow building not a flattering song
but then was I met it was a very nice go
did she say about the Beatles she loved
this he's a very nice guy she thought
they were great and there was one guy
who was with them who was giving them
bad information and bad information
about the Maharishi and some of them
believe that like George was the one who
stayed with it the most also Paul
McCartney does TM didn't get me I think
Stern does it like there's a lot of
people at dairy farm folk and they say
it's it's it's tremendously helpful and
I'm in
three-year what's that Lina actually I
don't want to give myself credit never
money she got me no I got judd apatow
antsy cooker era taught lina and my
woman and she taught Judd I got Judd
until judge said I want that judge
always a guy but Lee and I say this I
swear to god he's a nicest guy yeah but
he wants everything he wants to be
involved in everything he wants to be at
every party he wants you to give him up
he wants it all judge does and he's like
you're doing that meditate I want I want
that so I gave him her and so it was
passed along
she was remarkable and I'm lucky that I
had her that makes me want to do it I've
heard so many good things about a shoot
it's a really calm you I can't say
enough good things and by the way I also
I smoke pot but I smoke pot indica at
night when I when I'm feeling a little
restless
and I want to sleep and I smoke pot on
occasion just for enjoyment not all the
time no I have too many things to do
right that's expose wait there's one
negative from pot you don't get your
agenda done open that I see nothing
wrong with well I'm fascinated with like
Joe Rogan who can [ __ ] do edibles I
don't hunting and he's cooking elk and
he's doing it's like what the [ __ ] are
you doing yeah I think he's twins I
think he literally has a brother who
doesn't have to [ __ ] by the way might be
right well the thing is like you know
Doug Benson I don't know how much he
gets really deeply high anymore because
your body does build up in like an
immunity yeah he's easy smoking and I
thought his own [ __ ] I could get my Sony
ah but I but I think that might be true
with your Rogen to that you get to a
point where it doesn't you know I don't
know I'm not an expert on them when did
when did you learn Transcendental
Meditation
I learned it um I'll say ten years ago
maybe okay so is that hey Norman
Morrison yeah what made you do it
do you think we could look like
something cool I just want to try it
well no I was an over-thinker I was
filled with anxiety I still have some
anxiety but I'm a different person man
I'm I am so completely not
thinker I mean it's not like I accept
things but for example if I get pissed
off about the government I go outside
and look at a tree and appreciate if
there's a breeze even better I'm not
discounting what's going on but it just
puts me in a better place right balance
and just find anything else to think
about nothing on a big balance the
obsession with the negativity or
overthinking by the way the one thing I
don't think about ever is my career
really do it whatever I want to do I'm
going to get it done boom with you I've
been for years you're working you but
you work all the time because I do
stand-up constantly wrote and directed
and started in this movie yeah you've
got the Goldberg yes I'm about to do
another leaf on that axe that I'm
rewriting the commercial script was good
I see them make it more mine but a
directing and starring in it's not it's
not a mystery movie it's a different
movie do you like having your hands on
that Megan it's so much work especially
for somebody who I don't is the answer
because for example this past year I
filmed Curb Your Enthusiasm and the
Goldbergs at the same time yeah and it
didn't affect my work my work I stayed
focused on but it affected my joy a lot
of times I was just miserable and
overtired but I did what I had to do and
I feel not that I went mom not to my
knowledge was i jerky you know but I
felt jerky and you don't think about the
you don't think about the prestige or
where you are in career you just think
about that is or ever do I think that
and not only that I haven't even
achieved like the level of success I
want like I want to do as level you want
like the level of success you want like
we all look at a guy like a Seinfeld
like who do you look at and go like
that's a guy whose success I would be
cool it well to me it'd be more like
Albert Brooks or Woody Allen okay I want
to just put it but what I really want
right now and by the way I'm very
content and happy but I love working and
when you're successful as you guys know
you got to work harder to keep up the
success than making it with that
anything is so much harder than making
it you catch that feeling of like oh
this is what it feels like you're like
how the
like am I going to keep it yeah like how
do I stop going away the key is to
really work hard and do good work yeah
if you keep doing that once you're
successful it should all work out
the minute you sell out do something for
money you're screwed because people lose
respect for you if you're in a position
where people respect you but my goal is
to make like Frank Capra movies to make
movies like it's a wonderful life or
meet John Doe like movies that are a
larger budget but on theme about
humanity and the challenges I mean Trump
is such a great villain for you know a
Frank Capra movie you know but you went
to a smaller version of it yeah you know
well you got into college because those
old school guys like like I know Jimmy
Durante made you what no what happened
was I always loved comedy and my entire
level used to watch comedy on that
Sullivan Johnny Carson variety shows
remember the first time I saw Albert
Brooks was on the Flip Wilson show like
I saw but when I was 8 years old I was a
funniest kid in school but I didn't know
that that could be a job and we went to
see Jimmy Durante in Chicago and on the
way home I asked my parents if that was
a job and they said yes and I said well
that's a job that I want yeah it just
seemed fun right oh so fun you know my
favorite thing there and said yes though
they said it was a job because a lot of
there yes me not you right they said yes
it is a job technically my favorite
thing in terms of stand-up comedy
besides actually doing whatever I love
laughing at other comedians like I am so
my favorite comedian of all time was
Jack Benny and that with Jack Benny's
reputation that he laughed hard at other
comedians and I feel man I love laughing
I hate bad comedians but man you don't
enjoy watching comedians do poorly no
hate it I didn't love nothing more right
if we're sharing that experience like
the crowd hates us and there's no
winning that can be really joyful
amongst comedian yeah
and I've had that but you know I was
liking a guy go up and eat his balls
at all by the way to be truthful when
you eat it that's like saying oh the
comedian tonight was breathing air it
comes with the terrorists it comes in
like some guys bomb find Colin can bomb
funny hell is hilarious my god anyone
who's funny bombs funny that's right it
comes with it and when it's tragic is
when someone's not funny and you almost
want to go please let the scare you out
of the business
please get out gently but I'm not I
don't see that many people in that
situation like I used to as a younger
gromek and I thought why are they doing
it you know but when someone's funny if
the bombings hilarious because they're
being funny and they're more being funny
for you because then it becomes inside
you know and I love what I like about
watching a good bomb though is when you
watch a guy and you know all the tricks
will do to get out of it like when you
lapse into all right I got to do
something for me a piece of material
whatever you do the tricks and when the
tricks aren't working I'd like to get
the audience like when you're out there
exploring new material yeah it bombs
then we bring the audience back in
watching someone eat their dick and not
be able to pull out of it ah awesome
love it oh I saw what's-his-name oh crap
he passed away years ago he was Geraldo
Richard Kenny no no um before that
before not long before that shortly
before that um what say me went on he
went on to be huge in England Oh God
Bill Hicks Bill Hicks so I saw Bill
Hicks in Chicago once at the funny firm
comedy club which is no longer there and
I saw him eat it like huge time I saw
him get in a hole that I never see
anybody get into I'm so Mike this is
like a half hour in he's not getting any
laughs and he dug himself out of the
hole
in a way that I never seen anybody dig
themselves out a hole to when they end
I'm I guess there's a standing ovation
because those always like really a
standing ovation was her so hard to come
by mclubbe but by the end they loved him
and he was going I remember being with
Sam Kinison before same Kennison was
famous
I started in Fort Lauderdale he he came
down and of course
first time I saw him he was what he was
and so my eyeballs popped out of my head
like what is this
but the audience's reaction to him were
either it was killing at a level that
I'd never seen anybody kill or is if
somebody pulled a fire alarm and they
had to get on like I saw room of 300
people and I'm not exaggerating 3/4 of
them gone in 20 minutes Wow 3/4 but they
couldn't take it and he'd scream with
them Oh Isaac who those who liked it
liked it knows who hated it really hated
it but that shows he was great there you
I mean to me the greatest thing about
making films doing stand-up is sort of
living and dying by your personal sword
who are you what are you about you know
when an actor will ask hey man what are
they looking for
no no what do you have to give who are
you right because that might be not what
they're looking for and then they go we
want that they don't know about you will
never get it when you do what you think
they're looking right and that stand up
that's movies doesn't matter you got to
be you Jeff Jim thank you gesture pal
they're telling us jeff has to go we're
going to take a break but I love Jeff I
the movies on Netflix tomorrow
it's called handsome a Netflix mystery
movie and that you can get on Netflix
tomorrow all around the world
Garlan on instagram g AR li n and come
back anytime is so good to see Hanoi is
is great in this movie yeah Randy it's
got natasha Lyonne in it yeah there are
everyone great and I wrote the parts for
them so before they even said yes you
know yeah so great happen to anybody
what a joy to be here good to see you
guys are doing a great job thank you man
I say enjoy your good looks thank you
well yeah